hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
and i'm here to make a big big update on
amc
a lot of things are happening this week
again we are in the third wave
so let's see what the charts are telling
us let's get into it
[Music]
so four hours time frame in my last
video i was actually telling you guys
that
we were starting this third wave
of the third wave that is very impulsive
that we see the volumes kicking in
we see the volumes very good very well
on the daily time frame here so let's
see exactly the number of shares it's
interesting to see exactly the number of
shares
that were traded and i'm going to
explain very soon how i use this
information
yes around 200 million shares it's like
you know half of the share float roughly
so it's really a lot and i'm wanting to
show you something so if you're going
to finance you check the news so here is
amc's
ceo adam aaron so basically he's
thanking you know the apes for the
support
they're giving to his firm you know
right now they're actually calling him
civil back you know so he's like the
chief of like
the group of gorillas you know this is
what is a silverback
and what is very interesting in this
article is actually that
it's here guys three million investor
apes strong and the company's earning
coal iron revealed
amc had more than 3 million individual
shareholders
who owned more than 80
of its 450 million shares as of
march 11. so this is
a very big news i was actually looking
for this information you know you can
check
who is owning the share but you're
mostly gonna find some institutional
clients some
hedge funds in a citadel companies like
this but you don't know
who is the an investor and it's actually
information that is supposed to be
public but it's not easy to know what is
true or not
when the ceo is telling that 80 percent
of its shares
are actually owned by individual
investors
this is to me very good news it means
that you know only 20 percent
is left for you know other investors
that
don't invest the same way i would say so
this is very positive and here you can
see that around 150 200 million shares
are trading
every day so we know that apes are
buying now let's see what technicals are
actually giving us
here the first thing in my last video i
was telling you guys i think i did my
last video around like
here maybe here yeah i did it here
around 12. so i was telling you that
right now we are very bullish because we
are in this third wave so when i said
third wave i'm talking
of a larger degree wave counting so i'm
talking about this one the blue one
that to me is going to 25 and inside
this third wave we've completed the one
we had the second wave that was a bit
tricky
and now we are in the third wave of the
third wave that's itself going to
contain
five waves and in this five waves
development we only finish
the third wave so what i'm saying here
is that we're probably going to have a
bit of a correction until the
20th of may maximum it can go right away
you know i'm just giving you here kind
of you know bearish scenario which is
not bearish at all but
this consolidation might last a bit
longer that's what i'm saying
we actually arrive here to the 15th
level so i told you guys that this level
would be a very important level that we
need to take it back
uh that probably we're going to take it
back in the third wave then correct
and then reach another major level so
i'm going to
show you how i found this one so my
scenario is that we correct on the 20th
of may
so it has not changed actually this is
the same thing i had when i did my last
update on amc
and that then we're going to go to the
18 area y18 you might ask
and it's just basic field extensions
application
so you measure the first wave that is
here and you apply to the bottom of the
second wave
and usually the third compared to the
first
has a one-to-one relation or a one two
one point six one eight
relation in terms of ratio so here
my scenario we know when i combine this
information with my idiot with counting
it would actually give me a 18 target
for the highest level of this third of
the third
then from the correct 15 and reach the
1.618
which is no surprise here again guys
technical analysis usually
comes back to the same levels you know
even if we use different methods
here it's also the highest level we had
at the first wave
so this is the target for the fifth of
my third
so i'm gonna get rid of it it's just to
show you guys how i found
those levels you know i don't put them
here randomly
i put them here for a reason so i expect
we reach 18 around the 26th of may
then correct then go to 25. now let me
tell you why i need
to go there so quickly it's very
important we actually
go there quickly and let me show you why
guys there is something
i told you about many times during all
this
correction here i was telling you that i
was seeing a buddhist
divergence right so the bullish
divergence i was seeing
is that i think it was in the fullest
time frame let me show you this again
and this helped me to actually you know
to build my bullish view here
and to remain bullish despite this
complex correction
one second
so it's here guys right from here to
here the
the press action is making higher lows
and the magnet during the same time is
actually going
lower so we were having this bullish
hidden divergence all right you remember
guys for those who have watched my
previous video one month ago i was
telling you about that
i told you that market is making higher
lows which is bullish
despite the momentum indicator that i
use here the macd that is making
lower lows so this is what we call a
bullish
hidden divergence and this helped us to
be bullish and to actually
find the right answer here on this chart
thanks to this bullish hidden divergence
now guys why
do i need the price action to go there
so quickly because
look look what we are having here
we are having market making higher highs
soon all right for now we are still at
this level
true we are consolidating here and once
again guys this is totally normal
we gonna have some you know one two
three maybe even five days of
consolidation
but we cannot have too many of those we
need to go there quickly
because the quicker we go the higher the
macd is going to be
and right now guys if i assume we making
a
higher high here which is my scenario
i need the macd to go higher than the
level i had here
otherwise i'm going to have uh here
bearish divergence so it would be this
one
so market making high highs and it would
be the
bearish regular divergence market making
higher highs with the macd making
lower highs all right so we don't want
to see this
and for this not to happen we need the
price action to go there
quickly with a lot of strength with a
strong momentum
so it's exactly what we're having right
now we just need to keep seeing
those strong moves up if we arrive
here without if enough strength
we gonna probably get rejected and we
won't do this
fifth wave so we need to arrive here
strongly and i think we would
this is why i put this very bullish
scenario here so i expect amc
just to you know have an idea of what
i'm saying
but it's not that much it's like 30 you
know in in a matter of
one week so we need this to happen and
we need this macd to go
much higher here for the bullish case to
remain
intact one more thing quickly so what do
we have in terms
of uh volume first so as i said the
weekly volume 180 million shares guys
it's a lot
in terms of short interest the 30s of
april data
has arrived 88 million shares so roughly
the same as
on the 15th of april the synthetic short
when i compute
all the option market synthetic
exposure i have six percent of the total
share float that is shown in this market
300 million
us dollars of exposure and when i check
my indicator which is
uh i check the 40 strike volatility and
i can find for
june and september they are at 273
percent guys which is
amazingly high and 176 percent
to compare it was only 150 percent uh
two weeks ago
for the september maturity so this is
going higher this means that
option uh traders needs protection for
this 40 strikes
this is making the price action looking
very bullish and this could create a
gamma squeeze once again
if we go for example to 30 the synthetic
short exposure goes to 16
and you can see that it's coming mostly
for the fully strike
call so this is very bullish as well and
for now we are at 12.
so let me go back here all right and
we are having here the synthetic short
that i add to the short interest so we
having 27
of total shot interest of course here
i'm not taking into account the naked
shorts because i don't know about that
but i compare this data to this data and
i can see that we have more short
interest that we used to
in january so this is looking good to me
this
data just confirms my bullish case so
guys that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys